-Dua, one of your biggest fans
is a man named Papa Richy.
All right?
He's 80 years old,
and he went viral on TikTok
after his granddaughter
surprised him with tickets to
your concert for his birthday.
His reaction got over
7 million views.
This is real.
Check this out.
-"Admission ticket,
Richard L. Waldorf."
-"And Elena Waldorf."
-"Dua Lipa in concert"?!
Are you [bleep] me?!
[ Laughter ]
Really?!
Is this a real thing?
-Yeah!
-Holy [bleep]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh, it's just
such a good video.
-Yeah.
-It made me so happy.
-Well, since he's such
a huge fan of yours,
we wanted to give Papa Richy
another surprise.
And this is real.
It's happening right now, guys.
We reached out to him,
pretending that we were
a radio station, okay?
In New York, and told him
that he won a contest
for the number-one
TikTok video of the year.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
Amazing.
-He believed us.
He loved it, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
So, yesterday, we flew him and
his granddaughter to New York.
He's in our building right now
as we're talking.
The TV monitors are not on
in the building.
And he thinks he's about to be
interviewed on a radio show
and get a tour of "30 Rock."
And here he is
a few minutes ago.
We have GoPro cameras.
That's his --
[ Laughter ]
So he has no clue
what's going down.
And, in fact, someone --
There was some
"Tonight Show" sign,
and he said,
"Oh, I love "The Tonight Show.'"
[ Laughter ]
So I was like, "Oh, cool.
This is gonna be great."
-Well, he's gonna --
he's gonna get the surprise...
-Of his life.
-...of his life.
-All right, so right now,
we all need to be really quiet,
'cause, seriously,
he's being led to what he thinks
is the radio station.
And what he doesn't know is,
he's about to walk
onto "The Tonight Show"
and meet Dua Lipa.
[ Laughter ]
All right?
So, all right, let's get ready.
He's --
-Should I come with you?
-Yeah, you come with me.
We'll hear it.
We'll hear it when he's here.
-Ready as
we're ever gonna be.
-Your first radio interview?
-First radio interview.
-Oh, great, good.
-Papa, I will follow you.
-Okay.
I'm gonna follow.
-He's coming through.
I think we can hear him.
[ Laughs ]
-Well, I'll follow you, Pop.
-Okay.
-Okay? You first.
-I'm a real Jimmy Fallon fan.
-This is where Jimmy
always gets ready over here.
-Oh, my God!
Hi, Jim.
[ Laughter ]
-We'll just cut through, uh...
-Everyone,
please welcome Papa Richy!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Jimmy Fallon.
-Thank you.
-I'm Jimmy Fallon.
You're on "The Tonight Show."
This is Dua Lipa.
-Oh, my God!
[ Laughter ]
Holy [bleep]!
-Hi!
-Oh, my God!
Can I -- Can I shake your hand
or something?
-Of course.
-Yes.
-Okay.
-Hello.
-Your hands are freezing.
-My hands actually are freezing.
-And this is your --
This is your granddaughter?
-Yes, I'm Katie.
-Katie, how are you?
Jimmy.
-Hi, Katie.
-It's Katie's 22nd birthday.
-It's Katie's birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
-Happy birthday.
-What a present
this is right here.
-Yes.
-Now, I read something that said
that one of your dreams
is to dance with Dua Lipa.
-Yes, yes, of course.
[ Laughter ]
-Can we make --
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Can we make that dream
a reality?
Oh, my --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Hey, hey, hey ♪
Ooh!
All right, let's --
-You're supposed to be --
You're supposed to be on tour.
-My thanks to Dua Lipa!
-I am on tour.
-Papa Richy!
His granddaughter Katie!
Happy birthday!
Stick around!
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show" after the break.
♪♪
-We were at your first show.
-Oh, you were?
-In Miami.
-In Miami?
-Yes.
-Did you enjoy it?
-Loved it.
-I'm so happy.
-That first outfit you had on --
that green outfit.
-All right, all right,
come on, now.
[ Laughter ]
-All right, all right.
♪♪
-I got to dance with Dua!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You look fantastic.
-Thank you. Only for you.
-I mean, come on.
-You know I always
make a big effort
when I come on this show.
-You really always do.
I love it.
-I love you, bud.
-You know, helped us out
when we didn't have a show --
we didn't have an audience,
I was doing it in my home.
-Yeah.
-And you were so cool.
You Zoomed in to me in my home,
but I think --
I want to say
you were the first artist
to make a performance, a video.
-Yeah, I set up a green screen
in my living room --
-Yes, you made a whole video.
-For "The Tonight Show,"
and I just couldn't believe it.
I was like, "I can't believe I
have to set up a green screen
and do this.
-You were the first artist
to do that.
-It was amazing.
-Thank you for doing that.
-It turned out so good.
It's always kind of scary,
you know,
kind of getting in the zone
when it was so new.
-Everyone kind of followed
your thing and started doing
what you were doing, so I can't
thank you enough for that.
And congrats on your
Future Nostalgia Tour.
Just played the Garden.
-Yes.
-Oh, my gosh.
The Madison Square Garden.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Dua!
-Thank you.
-What was it --
Alright, talk to me.
-It was surreal.
It really exceeded
all my expectations.
I think when you go to a place
like New York, you always feel
like maybe people are gonna be
a bit more critical,
people are gonna, like...
-Sure.
-But everyone just kind of
rode the wave with me.
It was amazing.
They we were all up for it.
The floor was shaking.
-Yeah, when that place --
-It was -- it was brilliant.
It was brilliant. Loved it.
-When Madison Square Garden
rocks, it just rocks.
It's like this studio,
Studio 6B.
Here we go. This is it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's happening.
-Oh, the floor.
-The floor shakes.
-I can feel it.
-Yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
-People are talking about
the tour, crazy awesome reviews.
Congrats.
They love the costumes.
They love the dancing.
And on social media, they're
loving one dance in particular.
[ Light laughter ]
Yeah, and I love that
you did this 'cause...
Should I explain it,
or do you want to?
-I mean, you can start, and then
I'll, like, riff off it.
-I want to say it was like
in 2017-ish, around that time,
you did a dance that people --
some haters got online
and said this is a lazy dance
or something, it's uninspired.
-It was kind of like,
"Oh, she looks like she's trying
to put her shoe on in a rush
or something."
[ Light laughter ]
-Why do people just
have to be so mean?
-I think it's okay.
You know, today
when I look back on it --
and the reason I guess
why we're talking about it
is 'cause I've brought it back.
I'm doing it on my tour.
-Yeah.
-I'm reclaiming it because there
was a moment where, actually,
it caused me a lot of grief.
Like, I was being bullied
online.
It wasn't very nice.
But -- But now
I'm, like, you know,
I can look at it
from a different perspective.
I look back on it
with such fondness,
'cause it helped me grow into
the artist I wanted to become.
It made me, like, work harder.
I went in, I did more rehearsal.
I just wanted to become
a real performer,
and I think that was kind of
the thing that I needed.
-And now you open --
is it "Don't Start Now"?
-Yeah, I start
"Don't Start Now" with it.
-With that dance?
-Yep.
-And everyone goes nuts
'cause it's like,
"Yeah, see,
don't make fun of this.
Now I'm doing this every show,
so get ready."
Could you show me the move?
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'll do it with you.
-Will you do it with me?
Someone in the audience
was like, "Yeah!"
-Yeah.
-Someone's really excited.
I don't know if I can do it in
these boots, but you know what?
Snow, boots, rain, wind, shine,
whatever.
-You're Dua Lipa.
You can do anything, man.
-Okay.
-Alright.
That's it.
[ Audience cheers ]
I can't do it.
-Yep. Come on. Come on.
Hip, hip, hip, hip!
-This is embarrassing.
This is me doing it.
That is me doing it.
That is me doing it, by the way.
So bad.
[ Cheers and applause ]
See, that almost hurt me.
That's how old I am.
Oh, my God, how sad?
But I love that you did that.
I love that you
put it out there.
I just think you're cool.
I also -- I want to talk
about Elton John
while I can talk to you,
because that was the greatest
move of all moves.
"Cold Heart."
I'm like, "Oh, my gosh."
And it went to number one.
-It did.
-And, wait, so what's it like
working with Sir Elton?
-[ Exhales sharply ] It --
I mean, I have so many --
I'm so lucky to have so many
"pinch me" moments in my life.
-Yeah.
-And that's definitely
a massive one.
He's somebody I've looked up to
my whole life.
So to get to do
the song together,
to re-create his iconic songs --
-You crushed it, though.
-It's just a massive honor.
I'm so grateful.
And I get to perform it.
-And adding "Rocket Man"
in there, too.
Like, yo! So good!
-It's just amazing, and I get to
perform it night after night.
And it's just --
it's a dream come true.
I really -- in that moment,
I really just kind of
soak it all up
and I can't believe everything
that's happening to me.
-And then he gave you a very
nice gift, a memorable gift.
-He did give me a very lovely,
memorable gift.
Sir Elton John put a ring on it.
-He put --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ] I'm joking.
-You're marrying --
-Before this gets into the press
or whatever --
-You married Elton John?
-No, I didn't.
I didn't, I didn't, I didn't.
-Oh, okay.
-I think David would fight me.
-Yeah, he would. Of course.
-For sure.
-But he gave me a very beautiful
ring that belonged to him,
as just kind of, like, a token
when we performed together
for the first time.
And it was just -- I was just --
-How cool is that?
-Yeah.
I keep it...
-I love Elton John.
-I actually kept it at home
locked up in a safe
'cause I just don't think
it was safe back here.
-No, not on our show.
No, no, no, no.
[ Laughter ]
I'm famous for this.
I want to talk about --
you're always, again,
doing something new
and different.
And you have a new thing
called Service95.
It's a concierge newsletter.
-Mm-hmm.
-Now, that basically means
it tells you cool places to eat
that you've been to,
it tells you what you're doing
on tour.
It also interviews activists
and people doing stuff
to change the world.
It's fantastic.
-Thank you.
-I signed up for it.
-Thank you so much.
-Service95.com.
You just type in your email,
boom, off you go.
And it's in 11 different
languages.
-It is, yep.
And our podcast
is also translated
in three different ones.
Hopefully, over time,
we'll get to do more of that.
It's just -- it was really
a platform and a hub
where I could share
so many different sides.
Like, so many different
of my interests,
and things that I felt like
we can all learn
something new from,
in the process of learning
myself, exploring.
It's all about people
who just want to be
a little bit more curious,
you know,
kind of putting a mixture,
from, like you said,
recommendations to...
-There's art in there.
-There's art, there's music,
there's fashion,
there's activism.
There's all kinds of articles,
thought provoking...
-It's well done.
-...stories.
And it's just something
where I feel like...
I just want to kind of challenge
people's opinions
and give people
a different perspective
and give people,
different people a voice.
And I just --
I'm enjoying it so much.
It's been so fun to curate it,
and I've got an incredible team
that work with me on it.
-Are you enjoying your podcast,
as well?
-I'm loving the podcast.
-I mean, "At Your Service."
-It's really fun.
Yeah, "At Your Service."
-"At Your Service"
with Dua Lipa.
And you interview everybody.
-Yes, I do.
-You like interviewing people?
-I really do. I really do.
I really like the research
experience element of it,
and, like, again, the whole
learning experience
has been really, really fun.